how are ya thank you so do you
oh this is fabulous oh he's busy leave
him he's talking with the man like you
go do your thing and I'll see you later
well you look stunning thank you I'll
get out of here
you really do you look amazing mrs.
who'd that dress party this is Vera Wang
have a little Bulgaria diamantaires
stunning we know this about tonight um I
was I'm always nervous about stuff like
this because oh yeah yeah always nervous
right it mostly just the car ride over I
don't know it's just for some reason the
anticipation of waiting in a car when
you're all gussied up it's crazy man
just security getting in here now that
makes me nervous the whole thing makes
me nervous
but now that I'm talking to you I feel
better okay we're gonna win winning
winning chicken dinner right everybody's
a winner here Ivan I'm up for an award
for the worst interviewer on duty all
right
okay what were you wearing three hours
ago three hours ago I was wearing a
bathrobe and pasties cute cute cute
well have you got in your handbag Binaca
shoes my credit card $100 bill and my
phone we interviewed one lady my
driver's license
Oh have to bring your ID when you come
to the Golden Globes we interviewed one
lady and she had a pair of knickers in a
handbag why I wanted to know don't ask
I've never heard of that before
- you know what no later tonight we may
be hunting her down we don't know
where's that girl with the underwear
[Laughter]
um I believe that tonight I'm gonna be
with Noah Baumbach laura dern my lovely
fiancee and I think Randy Newman may be
at our table which I'm very excited I
can very excited I've never I'm not
gonna do that because I've never met him
but yeah but do you know what he reminds
her of a little hobbit I love him okay
well I'm not gonna tell me I don't know
that you that he reminds you okay
now would you do something for us
because the money goes to charity I won
and I want to come on oh it's all
drinking yes yes you have to sip it and
then say what charity and they give
$1,000 to cherries oh really
okay this is going to solar responders
what solar responders helps provide
solar panels for first response stations
in vulnerable areas like Puerto Rico so
and we chose Ely Cochise thank you
but how many of these have you had no I
have only had a Spitz really good
okay siblings failed yeah what's your
big secret to get you through award
season I'm sorry
dining stunning stunning was Nicole
Kidman alright I guess I gotta go
where's the biggest secrets who get into
a wood season this this the liquid gold
maybe I'm taking it with me
[Music]